four months on survivors are reliving
the pain of losing family members at sea
they were hoping to make it to Europe
but their boat was intercepted by the
Army off the coast of Northern Lebanon
in circumstances disputed till today
our goal is to know who is responsible
for sinking the boat we still don't know
there have been contradictory statements
the Army said the boat wasn't hit if the
captain of the submarine said it was hit
from the front
a few days ago a privately funded search
team located the wreckage more than 450
meters beneath the surface
the Army says it was overloaded and
collided with the Navy vessel while
trying to get away survivors say
otherwise
the Army vessel hit the front of our
boat Water started to come in and at
first we didn't realize the boat was
sinking I saw a sailor twice telling
them to hit the front of our boat
the captain of the submarine reported
signs of damage at the front of the boat
but says his team didn't have the
capabilities to retrieve the vessel
which is partly buried under silt on the
seabed
they were killed in Cold Blood who want
a transparent investigation and if they
were serious about the truth they would
bring the boat up
relatives of the more than 30 people
missing are not only asking for justice
what flew it they killed my daughter at
least give me her bones this is all I
want now so I can pray at her grave
the search team says it found somebody's
near and inside the Shipwreck but they
were badly decayed the tragedy in April
wasn't the first for Lebanon in
September 2020 a migrant boat drifted at
sea for days without food or water
before it was found four people died
including a child
then like now families of the victims
blame the authorities saying they
haven't even been told if any of the
remains were recovered
my children I want them it's not up to
the authorities what happens these are
my children not theirs
but the search team has ended its
Mission providing no closure to grieving
families
Tripoli Northern Lebanon